people love it
uh when i ask about book recommendations
in general
of course your journey is just beginning
but is there something that jumps out to
you
technical fiction philosophical sci-fi
coloring books blog posts you read
somewhere
that had an impact on your life uh video
games
that you recommend to others minecraft
manual
manga i mean yeah video you could
mention video games too that
if there's something that jumps out to
you that just had like an impact
um i guess i'll say i really like the
book the
the war of art um which is a book about
creative resistance and the creative
struggle and what it means to be
creative
yeah um and part of what i see in this
conversation and what you're doing lex
is
so much of the war of arts idea is that
you just keep
writing and writing and writing until
you get to the new crap
yeah yeah and yeah you just you just
you just roll with it right and that's
sort of what happens when you have like
three hour conversations with people is
yeah you can only have so much scripted
or
societally constructed stuff until
you get to the real you and you have to
show up i mean he's that book that book
is kind of painful
it's really painful and it's not
something i would recommend for every
part of it
but for what it did in my life at the
time it also kind of normalized
i don't know um i part of my coming of
age story
is the part of it's about realizing that
i'm a creative person and person who
needs to create
um that's sort of a god-given thing i
think for a lot of people
but it's something that i don't really
feel like i can live without
and part of it was realizing that even
within some of these more rigid
structures it's okay that i don't sort
of
fit in with them and to hear about the
struggles of other creatives
was something for my own self-esteem and
my own growing up that was really
important to me
so i don't think the book itself might
be perfect
but for what it did for my life it was
really impactful
yeah i think exactly the words may not
be uh
exactly right by way of advice but i
think the journey that a lot of creators
take
by reading that book is uh kind of
profound
he also has another one called turning
pro i think i mean he in general
espouses like
taking it seriously like if you have a
creative mind and you want to create
something special in this world
go do it it's not don't you know show up
and so many blank pages so many people
would like tell me like
would encourage me either blatantly or
through like
implicit means to like basically take
the app less seriously
it's a good signal by the way um
it's a good signal because my really
close friends the ones who have always
supported me
yeah they never said that because they
got it they understood that was
that that was my path and they might be
skeptical they might be like
i mean one of my friends i remember told
me like i was always like taken aback
about why you were so certain this would
work out
and he's like i finally got it like once
i saw it like popping off but like
before that i just didn't get it but
like he still supported me
and i think i think it's a really good
signal and actually
just the fact of going through this
process has made me
socially feel so much more connected and
i've somewhat consolidated my social
life to some degree but it's so much
more
vulnerable connected and that's part of
the creative process
i have to thank for that i think this
there's something that's like
unstoppable about the creative mind it's
like it's right there that fire and
i guess part of the part of the
thing that you're supposed to do is let
that fire burn in whichever direction
and it's gonna hurt it's gonna hurt fire
will hurt
you